Musique douce
...
Musique tonique
-Etes-vous prêts ?
Allez.
-Nous sommes au Sénégal,
où une méthode unique au monde
est en cours.
Une association,
Pour le sourire
d'un enfant,
qui gère des enfants
en situation de conflit avec la loi
utilise un sport étonnant,
magique,
pour les aider à se réinsérer.
Ce sport, c'est l'escrime.
Musique douce traditionnelle
C'est à Thiès,
à 70 kilomètres de Dakar,
que j'ai rencontré Nelly Robin.
Elle est à l'initiative
de cette méthode inédite.
Tout a commencé il y a 25 ans.
J'ai découvert cette femme
pour un documentaire
que je faisais avec mon père
sur les enfants des rues.
-Lundi 10 janvier 2000.
Il est 10h du matin.
Nous sommes en train
de rouler vers la gare de Thiès.
Des gamins
ont en effet signalé à Nelly
la présence d'un enfant
qui traîne sur les voies ferrées.
-Eh, viens ici.
Va au conteneur,
il y a des enfants.
Les enfants parlent en même temps.
...
-25 ans plus tard,
l'association et Nelly
continuent leur combat,
et leurs méthodes
donnent des résultats
qui dépassent
toutes les espérances.
Aujourd'hui,
l'association a été appelée
pour récupérer un enfant.
Comment il vous a été confié,
cet enfant ?
-En l'occurrence,
c'est un enfant
qui a été très probablement trouvé
dans la rue
par une personne
qui l'a conduit à la police.
La police l'a signalé
au service de l'enfance du tribunal
qui nous ont appelés
pour nous le confier,
conformément à l'agrément
que nous avons
avec le ministère de la Justice,
depuis 1999.
-Cet enfant est conduit
dans le foyer d'accueil
qui existe depuis 30 ans.
Il sera entièrement pris en charge
par les éducateurs.
Ils parlent en langue étrangère.
...
-Il a été torturé, cet enfant ?
-Oui, il a été torturé.
C'est pas la première fois,
parce qu'il y a
des anciennes cicatrices.
-Il a été torturé par qui ?
-Par son frère.
...
-Il veut partir avec nous ?
Musique douce
...
-Il vient avec toi.
-Il veut partir avec moi, l'enfant ?
...
Vous êtes dans l'association
depuis combien de temps ?
-27 ans. Depuis 94,
je suis ici au foyer.
-Et vous y faites quoi ?
Institutrice,
mais j'ai fait plus
qu'enseigner.
Bon, je suis là comme une maman
qui essaie de combler
le vide affectif
qu'il manque aux enfants.
-Ils vont où ?
-Ils vont se faire un peu beaux.
Regarde comment ils sont.
Elle rit.
Je suis là comme une maman,
dans sa famille, avec ses enfants.
Tout ce qu'une maman fait
dans une maison,
dans une famille,
avec ses enfants,
je le fais.
Je m'occupe
de l'hygiène vestimentaire,
corporelle,
des chambres
et tout, tout, tout.
...
-Ah, mais vous faites
du football, aussi ?
...
-Oh !
-Et voici madame Tiamé
qui est en train de contrecarrer
Mbappé sur le terrain.
...
L'association travaille aussi
sur le terrain de foot
de la ville où de nombreux enfants
se retrouvent chaque jour.
La plupart
sont des talibés.
Ce sont des enfants confiés
à des chefs religieux
appelés marabouts.
...
Autre personnage emblématique
de l'association,
c'est Jacques.
Il travaille
dans l'association depuis 30 ans.
Il s'occupe
des enfants talibés
en étroite collaboration
avec les marabouts
dans les écoles coraniques.
Ce sont les daaras.
Avec le temps, il est devenu
éducateur de la méthode Escrime
et Justice Réparatrice.
Musique inspirante
...
L'enfant chantonne.
Ca, c'est les enfants
d'une daara ?
-Oui, ils sont à l'intérieur.
Je les ai amenés ce matin.
Je les ramène.
-Il y en a combien, à peu près ?
-Une cinquantaine.
...
Passe avant.
Passe arrière.
Allongé, fente.
Allongé.
Fente.
Arrière.
Passe avant.
Passe arrière.
Allonge bien le bras.
Fente.
Arrière.
Reviens à la position.
Un, deux, trois.
Applaudissements
...
Elle récite des sourates.
-Actuellement dans le monde,
il y a beaucoup de violences
qui sont basées sur l'intolérance.
L'ouverture de Thierno
vis-à-vis de nous,
vis-à-vis du travail,
c'est un magnifique exemple,
et qu'on puisse dire
aujourd'hui,
dans notre monde,
qu'il y a des lieux comme ça,
c'est très important.
Jacques, il est chrétien,
c'est un secret pour personne.
Thierno, il est musulman,
c'est un secret pour personne,
mais c'est avant tout des hommes
qui sont là pour les enfants
et c'est pour ça
qu'ils se rencontrent.
Je trouve que dans le monde actuel,
c'est un message
extrêmement important.
Les enfants chantent.
...
-C'est quoi, Thierno ?
Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
-Là, c'est la méthode
Escrime et Justice Réparatrice.
-C'est quand même
l'aboutissement de...
De...
Ouais, de neuf ans de travail.
-C'est quoi ?
-Eh bien, c'est la méthode
Escrime et Justice Réparatrice,
écrite.
Il y a tout l'exposé
des principes de la méthode
et c'est suivi
de la description
de 60 leçons
qui sont développées
avec les mineurs.
Voilà, super truc.
-Vous êtes contente ?
-Oui, oui,
c'est quand même...
C'est une première
pour l'association.
C'est aussi l'illustration
de la qualité du partenariat
avec l'administration pénitentiaire.
Donc voilà, c'est...
C'est un instant fort.
Voilà.
-Bravo !
-L'ambassadeur de France
a voulu se rendre
au sein de la prison
pour tenter de comprendre
cette méthode révolutionnaire.
Comment l'escrime peut être
aussi bénéfique pour les mineurs ?
-Inspecteur régional de l'enfance.
-Intrigué par cette méthode
auprès des détenus,
l'ambassadeur a voulu rencontrer
le personnel pénitentiaire.
-J'ai beaucoup entendu parler
de ce programme et de ses succès
pour la prévention
de la récidive.
-Depuis que nous avons commencé
l'expérience,
quand ça va jusqu'au bout,
il n'y a jamais eu
de retours négatifs.
Ca contribue véritablement
à réduire
ce qu'on appelle la récidive.
Donc, tous les jeunes
qui ont participé
à l'activité d'escrime,
on peut dire que depuis lors,
on ne les reçoit plus
dans la prison.
-On intervient à la prison
de Thiès depuis 1991.
On a reconstruit
la grande détention adulte
en 1998,
le premier quartier mineur.
Ensuite, on a construit
un second quartier mineur,
plus VIP, on va dire.
On avait créé le quartier femmes
car au départ, la prison de Thiès
n'était pas destinée
à recevoir des femmes.
Petit à petit, elles sont arrivées.
On avait aménagé un quartier femmes
dans un magasin
que vous aviez eu la gentillesse
de mettre à notre disposition.
Dernièrement, on a construit
un quartier femmes
en essayant
de mettre en place
un petit espace
pour les femmes qui ont leur bébé,
chez qui, souvent,
ça pose des petites difficultés.
On est à la disposition
de la MAC
en fonction des besoins :
hospitalisation,
accouchement...
Enfin, voilà,
ce qui est nécessaire.
-Oui, c'est une passionnée
de la prison.
A chaque fois qu'on a besoin,
qu'on fait appel à elle,
elle n'hésite pas.
Elle connaît bien la prison,
ça date même d'avant moi.
Je peux dire qu'elle maîtrise
mieux que moi cette prison.
On pourra jamais assez
la remercier.
-Si on a pu faire ça,
c'est parce que
l'administration pénitentiaire
a ouvert ses portes,
et que parvenir à construire
ce niveau de collaboration,
ça reflète la disponibilité
de l'administration pénitentiaire
et son souci
de l'attention aux détenus.
On vous invite à voyager,
mais notre bus, c'est un bus...
-Ca va,
je suis pas en sucre.
-Vous voyez,
il n'est pas très en forme, quoi.
Ils rient.
-Ce fut un plaisir
de vous accueillir.
-Plaisir partagé.
Merci à vous.
Merci pour votre accueil.
-Allez, jeunes gens. Hop !
Rire
Propos inintelligibles
Il rit.
Brouhaha
Bon, je vais me mettre debout,
comme tout le monde.
Ca te rappelle
des souvenirs ?
Tu l'as fait souvent,
ce voyage ?
-Oui.
-Tu as le sourire,
quand on en parle,
donc c'est
des bons souvenirs.
-Des bons souvenirs.
-J'ai rencontré Fallou
il y a 10 ans.
Il était alors prisonnier
et accusé
d'association de malfaiteurs.
Il a pratiqué l'escrime
au sein de l'association,
et aujourd'hui, il s'en est sorti
de manière admirable.
Parce que
je suis foutu.
Je suis foutu.
-Ca fait quoi,
de refaire de l'escrime ?
-Du plaisir.
Que du plaisir.
Beaucoup de plaisir
et du souvenir.
Brouhaha
-Ca t'a fait quoi,
l'escrime ?
-Pourquoi ça t'a
amélioré l'esprit, l'escrime ?
Je me suis fait respecter
par moi-même.
Brouhaha
-Aucun enfant passé
par ce programme
n'a récidivé.
Comment peut-on arriver
à une telle efficacité ?
Et pourquoi l'escrime,
et non pas un autre sport ?
-Ca fait très longtemps
qu'on travaille
avec les mineurs en détention,
et on s'est aperçu
que ces jeunes
arrivaient dans des situations
de plus en plus complexes.
Les garçons particulièrement
accusés
d'association de malfaiteurs,
et puis, les filles,
de plus en plus,
accusées d'infanticide
et d'avortement,
et on s'est dit que,
pour ces jeunes,
il fallait essayer
de proposer quelque chose
qui leur permette
de retrouver l'estime de soi,
de contrôler, aussi,
un petit peu,
leur colère,
et de reconstruire
leur identité.
Musique douce
...
Moi, j'avais observé,
dans des clubs d'escrime,
en France,
que des enfants qui étaient
plus qu'hyperactifs,
quelquefois très caractériels,
lorsqu'ils entraient
sur une piste d'escrime,
leur personnalité
se transformait.
C'est-à-dire : ils acceptaient
les règles de l'escrime.
-Marchez.
Marchez.
-Et quand les problématiques
que j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure
se sont posées,
et que l'objectif,
c'était d'éviter la récidive,
parce qu'on était
sur des jeunes
qui pouvaient avoir
jusqu'à 7-8 récidives,
à ce moment-là,
je me suis dit :
"Peut-être que l'escrime,
c'est une piste à explorer."
-Au début, quand même,
comme mes autres collègues,
je crois que
je n'étais pas sûre.
On était
un peu réticents.
Parce qu'on n'était
pas informés.
-Il faut avouer que,
de prime abord,
j'ai eu une inquiétude.
Je me disais :
"L'escrime en milieu carcéral ?",
pensant que l'épée
était dangereuse.
-Le fleuret,
je me disais :
"Les gens peuvent se blesser
avec ça, c'est une arme."
Je n'avais pas compris.
Mais quand j'ai fait
de l'escrime,
j'ai vu que, vraiment,
personne ne peut se blesser avec ça.
C'est là
que j'ai compris :
"Ah, d'accord ! Donc,
ce n'est pas une arme, c'est un...
Elle rit.
"C'est quelque chose
pour faire le sport."
-Si vous voulez, l'escrime,
c'est une histoire de deux choses,
entre l'être humain
et l'arme.
D'accord ?
L'arme est tenue par la main,
sur le bras,
et c'est le prolongement
de mon esprit.
-Tu peux te contrôler toi-même.
-Oui,
te contrôler toi-même.
Musique douce
...
-Ce qu'il faut préciser,
c'est que la pratique de l'escrime
y compris pour les mineurs
en détention,
dans cette méthode,
s'effectue à l'extérieur
de la prison.
Nous, au début,
on a souhaité cela,
parce qu'on restait attachés
au fait que, normalement,
selon les droits de l'homme,
les mineurs
ne doivent pas aller
en prison.
Si on doit leur proposer
quelque chose,
c'est à l'extérieur
de la prison.
L'autre objectif était
qu'ils puissent pratiquer
après leur détention.
Si on limitait
la pratique de l'escrime
dans l'espace carcéral,
ils ne peuvent pas, venir, après,
en détention.
Musique pop dynamique
Rire
...
Brouhaha
-Ca a changé beaucoup de choses
pour moi.
Exemple :
tu es en prison,
six mois que tu parles pas
avec un mec,
mais avec l'escrime,
je parle avec tout le monde,
car je viens ici, je parle,
on fait des combats et tout,
à cause de ça,
ils sont devenus des amis.
Propos indistincts et rires
-Au début,
je me disais à chaque fois
qu'ils pouvaient partir.
Mais maintenant,
il y a un climat
de confiance
qui s'est établi,
entre ces détenus
et moi.
A chaque fois, je les taquine
en leur disant :
"Les enfants,
il ne faut pas partir, hein ?"
Ils répondent :
"Nous n'allons pas partir."
Musique douce enjouée
...
Chocs métalliques
-On lève la main
quand on est touché. Donc,
quand l'adversaire vous touche,
vous levez la main,
et lui aussi,
il doit faire la même chose.
Ca éduque les enfants
à accepter,
quand on a fait
des bêtises,
à accepter de dire :
"J'ai commis une bêtise."
Chocs métalliques
Ronronnement du moteur
...
-Comme vous le savez,
nous avons un agrément de la justice
depuis 1994
qui nous permet de participer
à l'audience des mineurs,
où nous avons
une voix consultative.
Mais nous avons remarqué
que les mineurs
qui pratiquent l'escrime,
et les magistrats disent :
"L'enfant qui ne varie pas
dans ses déclarations,
"de l'enquête préliminaire
jusqu'à l'audience,
"cet enfant-là
est prêt à s'amender."
Donc, tous les enfants
qui pratiquent l'escrime,
une fois qu'ils sont
en audience,
ils sont élargis,
ils sont libérés.
Musique paisible
...
-On leur apprend tout juste
à prendre des décisions.
Ce sont des enfants
qui n'osent pas prendre
des décisions.
Là, on les soumet
à être responsables
de leurs actes,
à prendre des décisions,
à juger.
...
Ca sollicite l'ouverture d'esprit,
la communication,
et l'honnêteté.
Attaque, non.
Là-bas, la riposte.
Touché. Point.
2-1.
-Il est devenu responsable,
grâce à l'escrime.
Il a connu
l'arbitrage de l'escrime tôt.
-J'aimais beaucoup arbitrer,
parce que je sentais que là,
j'étais le responsable, en fait,
de ce match.
Je véhiculais des messages.
Lorsqu'une personne, parfois, tombe,
c'est à moi d'arrêter le match.
Lorsqu'une personne est blessée,
c'est à moi d'intervenir.
En fait, c'est une responsabilité
qui était lourde,
en quelque sorte,
dans ma tête,
et que...
J'essayais toujours
de voir comment gérer les matchs
et comment même organiser
les tournois.
-Riposte, 12 points. 1-1.
En garde.
-Etre arbitre,
ça veut dire qu'il y a
une certaine responsabilité.
On vous fait confiance.
On fait confiance à votre jugement.
-Halte ! Halte ! En garde !
-Et ça, c'est important,
parce que tout simplement,
ça leur permet de multiplier
leurs positions,
à l'instant,
dans le sport, dans l'escrime,
mais dans la société future.
Ca veut dire qu'ils seront pas
toujours confrontés
au corps-à-corps,
ou en vis-à-vis,
mais ils seront appelés aussi
à pouvoir trancher,
prendre des décisions.
-L'attaque, ça passe.
La contre-attaque, oui, pour moi.
Touche. Point.
3-1.
Garde.
Prêts ? Allez.
Musique calme
...
-Prenez position !
1...
1, 2, 3.
Eh ! C'est la même ligne !
Propos en langue étrangère
...
Voilà.
Prêts ?
Eh ! Eh !
En garde !
Prêts ?
Allez ! Voilà !
Dans tout combat,
il faut saluer l'adversaire.
Ca fait partie des rites
de l'escrime.
Ca veut dire que même en jouant
avec mon camarade,
je dois pas avoir de haine
contre lui,
parce que c'est le jeu.
Musique entraînante
...
-Je crois
qu'il y a beaucoup à faire,
parce que le détenu
qui ne te respecte pas,
il pense que c'est à cause de toi
qu'il est là.
Il a tendance à te regarder
comme un ennemi.
Du coup,
s'il pratique l'escrime,
il saura que celui-là
n'est pas son ennemi,
c'est juste son adversaire du jour.
Musique légère
...
-Je pense que mettre le masque
leur permet de laver leur honneur,
d'oublier
ce qu'ils avaient déjà commis
comme bêtises,
ce qui les a conduits en prison.
Allez.
En exercice.
-En anthropologie,
dans la tradition africaine,
le port du masque
a justement un symbolisme très fort.
Ils sont tous en blanc,
ils portent tous des masques,
donc il y a une certaine uniformité
qui fait qu'ils sont
tous pareils, tous égaux.
-En exercice !
-Ce sont des jeunes
en pleine construction
d'identité,
donc on a travaillé là-dessus,
sur comment chacun peut construire
individuellement
son identité.
Il n'a pas besoin
du regard des autres.
Et de ce point de vue là,
le masque est
un élément fondamental.
On s'est aperçu
que mettre le masque,
ça permettait de redevenir
ce que l'on est,
et de ne pas être seulement
ce qu'on l'on pense
que l'autre souhaite que l'on soit.
-Je pense qu'à partir du moment
où il y a eu le masque,
et le début du combat,
assez rapidement,
je pense qu'ils ont oublié
qu'il y avait filles et garçons,
tout simplement
parce qu'il y avait une formation
qui ne faisait pas de différence.
Les filles ont été prises en charge
comme les garçons,
avec les mêmes exercices,
les mêmes exigences, etc.
A partir de là, assez rapidement,
ça s'est bien passé.
Musique douce
...
-T'es très forte en escrime ?
-Oui.
-On m'a dit que tu gagnais
les garçons.
-Oui.
-Tu gagnes les garçons ?
-Non !
-Si !
Je gagne très bien.
J'ai gagné les garçons.
-Jouer avec une fille, déjà,
ça veut dire que cette fille-là,
c'est un alter ego,
parce que si tu es en duel
avec quelqu'un,
ça veut dire que vous avez
une certaine égalité de statut,
de force, etc.
Ca veut dire que cette personne-là
peut vous défier et vous battre.
Et le fait que cette fille-là
vous batte,
ça vous aide à vous réinventer,
mais aussi à retrouver une identité,
parce qu'on apprend
à respecter cette femme.
Si vous la respectez,
peut-être qu'à travers elle,
vous respecterez toutes les autres
et que vous apprendrez à respecter
votre alter ego, quel qu'il soit.
C'est donner à cette fille-là aussi
une confiance en elle.
Et le fait de donner
à cette fille-là
cette opportunité-là
de confronter un garçon,
c'est lui montrer que ce garçon-là,
ce n'est pas un être supérieur.
Il n'y a pas de supériorité,
aussi bien au niveau de la force
qu'au niveau du caractère, etc.
-Grâce à l'escrime,
on parle aux filles.
Là-bas, c'est interdit.
Il y a le quartier femmes.
Tu ne peux pas causer
avec les filles.
Donc là, à cause de l'escrime,
on peut parler avec les filles,
avec les garçons,
avec monsieur Nils,
avec tout le monde !
Musique douce
...
-Quand vous regardez
les assises, les procès,
la plupart des cas,
pour les femmes,
ce sont des cas d'infanticides.
Quand il y a infanticide,
c'est parce que
ce sont des grossesses
non désirées.
-Le débat
sur l'avortement médicalisé
en cas de viol ou d'inceste
a été relancé au Sénégal.
Il s'agit aujourd'hui
d'une question de santé publique.
Le code pénal du Sénégal
adopte en 1962
une peine de prison
pour les femmes
ayant recours à l'avortement.
La loi est confirmée en 2005.
Les jeunes filles
accouchent donc seules,
dans des conditions dramatiques,
qui entraînent souvent
la mort du nouveau-né.
Elles sont accusées
d'avortement clandestin
ou d'infanticide,
et condamnées à des lourdes peines
d'emprisonnement.
Il leur est rarement proposé
les soins obstétriques nécessaires.
L'association
Pour le sourire d'un enfant
a construit un poste de santé
dans le quartier Ablaye Yakhine,
un quartier pauvre de Thiès.
-C'est la couveuse.
-Couveuse.
-C'est ça !
-Moi, je suis sage-femme.
Il m'arrive de trouver
des jeunes filles
de 13 ans, 14 ans,
qui ont commencé à pratiquer
l'acte sexuel depuis longtemps.
Elles ont subi de la pédophilie
à bas âge, sans le dire.
Si elles trouvent quelqu'un
qui est mal intentionné,
qui leur donne de l'argent.
Elles peuvent faire ça comme...
Comment dirais-je ?
Elles peuvent s'habituer
à l'argent facile.
C'est très souvent
ce genre de filles-là
qui évolue
avec des grossesses précoces.
Quand c'est
une grossesse non désirée,
des fois, elles se cachent.
Elles peuvent continuer la grossesse
jusqu'à l'accouchement,
elles peuvent fuguer à ce moment
et accoucher ailleurs.
Très souvent,
ces jeunes filles-là,
elles n'accouchent pas
au sein de la maison.
Elles accouchent
au bord de la mer,
dans des cabanes,
et autres.
-Il y a des gens qui les assistent,
à ce moment-là,
ou elles accouchent toutes seules ?
-Elles peuvent accoucher
toutes seules.
-Une femme,
elle peut accoucher toute seule ?
Donc elle prend le bébé,
elle le sort elle-même ?
-Oui, ça arrive.
-Qu'est-ce qu'elles font du bébé,
après avoir arrêté la grossesse,
pour accoucher...
...autre part
que dans un centre de soins ?
-Elles creusent
pour enterrer l'enfant.
Elles creusent,
ou bien elles trouvent un sachet,
un sac poubelle,
de n'importe quel type,
pour envelopper l'enfant
et puis s'en aller.
Ces grossesses-là,
ce sont des jeunes filles
à peine majeures
qui tombent enceintes.
Elles sont souvent à l'école,
avec les conséquences qu'on sait.
Même si la loi l'interdit
au Sénégal,
les filles sont renvoyées
quand elles tombent enceintes.
-Elles sont renvoyées de l'école
et de leur famille ?
-Elles sont rejetées par la famille,
par la société.
Il y a une forte stigmatisation.
-Rejetées par les croyances ?
-Rejetées par les croyances.
-Et enfermées ?
-Et enfermées.
-Donc ce n'est pas une double peine,
c'est quatre fois la peine.
-Oui. On peut... C'est...
Ce sont plusieurs peines à la fois.
-Quelle que soit l'origine
de cette grossesse précoce
non désirée,
elles...
La violence de la situation
se traduisait chez elles
par un abandon de leur corps.
C'est-à-dire qu'elles
le délaissaient complètement,
comme s'il y avait une dissociation
entre leur esprit et leur corps.
Et donc, l'important,
c'est de réunir les deux,
pour qu'il y ait effectivement
réparation.
Et l'escrime,
qui est exigent, en fait,
en termes physique et de posture,
l'habit blanc
et de nouveau le masque,
leur ont permis progressivement,
presque à leur insu, en fait,
de se réapproprier
leur corps,
et de réconcilier
leur esprit et leur corps.
On avait espoir qu'effectivement,
comme ça avait été
quelque chose de conçu
avec des professionnels
de l'escrime
et des professionnels
de la santé mentale,
qu'il y ait un effet,
mais un effet à ce point-là,
et surtout dans la durée...
C'est-à-dire que les jeunes
qui sont la première promotion,
comme l'on dit,
c'est-à-dire ceux
qui ont pratiqué en 2012,
aujourd'hui encore,
si on les rencontre,
ils expliquent,
dans leur vie actuelle,
ce qu'ils ont appris
à travers l'escrime,
c'est-à-dire vivre autrement,
un certain nombre de valeurs,
qui leur donnent une autre place
dans la société,
c'est aussi ce qui structure
encore aujourd'hui leur vie.
Donc ça, c'est un effet incroyable.
-Voilà, il y avait des chèvres ici.
Les années passées...
-Terrible ?
-Oui, les années passées.
Mais grâce à vous,
il est devenu
un garçon normal,
très sérieux,
correct, respectueux.
Donc, je te remercie mille fois.
Vraiment, merci.
-Mon père est très content.
Il est très content !
-Vous aviez peur ? Pourquoi ?
-Il se barre !
-Ca, c'est moi qui le dis.
-T'en vas pas !
-Il a un joli coeur !
Musique douce
-Ta maman dit
que t'as un joli coeur !
Eh !
Musique intrigante
...
-On est perdus, Nils ?
-On est en train
de chercher un enfant
qui a fait de la prison,
mais on sait pas où il faut aller.
On va trouver,
mais on est
au milieu du Sénégal,
dans un endroit où on voit bien
que ça devient un désert.
-On n'a pas de GPS ?
-Ils marchent pas, les GPS.
Musique douce
...
Propos indistincts
Il rit.
Propos en langue étrangère
...
Est-ce que tu as envie de me dire
pourquoi et combien de temps
tu as été à la MAC ?
Si tu veux pas, tu me dis pas.
*Notification de message reçu
-Il était accusé...
C'est pour savoir
de quoi il a été accusé ?
-Accusé de vol.
-Il a été accusé de vol.
-D'accord.
Combien de temps tu as fait
dans la prison ?
L'homme traduit la question.
-Deux ans, deux mois.
-Quand t'es rentré dans la prison,
t'avais quel âge ?
...
-17 ans.
-D'accord.
Ca t'a fait quoi,
de rentrer en prison, au début ?
...
Propos en langue étrangère
On rit.
-C'était difficile.
C'était difficile.
-Les gens qui passent
par le programme d'escrime
à la MAC de Thiès,
ils récidivent pas.
Pourquoi tu penses
que l'escrime les aide ?
Propos en langue étrangère
-Il dit que l'escrime,
ça t'ouvre les yeux
et ça t'ouvre l'esprit.
A la sortie, tu sais déjà
ce que tu dois faire après,
au lieu d'y retourner.
-T'as joué avec des filles ?
...
-Il dit qu'il a joué
avec des filles.
-Tu gagnais ou tu perdais ?
...
Il rit.
Des fois, il gagnait.
Des fois,
les filles gagnaient aussi.
-Est-ce que votre fils,
il a changé avec l'escrime ?
...
-Il dit qu'il ne sait pas trop
ce que c'est que l'escrime,
mais il sait que l'enfant
réfléchit et pense beaucoup
avant de faire quelque chose.
...
Elle dit que depuis sa sortie,
pratiquement
toutes ses fréquentations,
il les a abandonnées.
Quand on lui demande
de faire quelque chose,
il le fait.
Donc, il est confiant
par rapport à lui-même, quoi.
Vraiment,
ça l'a rendue fière, quoi.
Elle est toute contente.
-Vous pouvez être fiers
de votre fils, tous les deux.
...
C'est, quoi, le poulet, Jacques ?
-C'est un cadeau.
-Qui t'a donné ça ?
-C'est la maman d'Ibrahima.
-Merci, madame.
...
Merci à vous tous.
-Merci.
...
Musique douce
-Parmi les plus de 400 mineurs,
maintenant,
qui ont pratiqué l'escrime,
selon cette méthode,
en milieu carcéral,
eh bien, aucun n'a récidivé.
Donc, voilà.
Un reviendra ou une reviendra
inévitablement,
mais en tous les cas,
le résultat est au-delà
de nos espérances. Ca, c'est clair.
La foule hurle.
...
Musique entraînante
-Pendant le tournage
de ce documentaire,
je faisais en même temps
un film de fiction avec Dadju,
qui était en concert à Dakar.
Je lui ai proposé
de venir voir l'association.
-Bonjour. Enchanté.
-Enchantée.
Merci beaucoup
d'être venu jusqu'à nous.
Les enfants sont ravis
de vous accueillir.
-Tant mieux.
-Ils sont très heureux.
Vous voulez les saluer ?
-Let's go.
Percussions
Propos indistincts
...
-On a mis en place
une méthode particulière.
-L'escrime.
-Escrime et Justice Réparatrice,
pour...
...pour leur permettre
de se reconstruire.
C'est assez spectaculaire.
-Passe avant.
Passe arrière.
Marchez.
Allongez.
Fente !
En garde !
-L'escrime en vrai...
-Ben voilà !
-C'est la première fois.
J'en ai toujours vu à la télé.
C'est impressionnant quand même.
-Ouais.
-Avant, tous ces enfants
allaient à la prison.
-OK.
-On a négocié avec les magistrats
petit à petit
pour qu'ils soient confiés ici
plutôt que d'aller à la prison.
-OK.
-L'impact que ça a...
-Vu les résultats...
-Qui est l'escrimeur
du soir ?
-Yeah !
-Ca se met comment ?
-Alors, celle-ci,
je vais...
-Comme ça.
-Comme ça ?
Je dois avancer ?
-C'est quoi, la règle ?
-Il faut saluer d'abord
votre adversaire.
Propos indistincts
...
On applaudit.
-Ah oui.
-C'est physique, hein ?
-Oui.
-Dadju, tu veux faire ?
-Non, c'est bon.
-Merci, hein.
Merci.
-Merci.
-T'es en sueur.
-Je suis en sueur, laisse tomber.
-Ca tue.
-C'est pour ça qu'on dit
qu'il y a des choses
qu'il faut vivre.
-Exactement.
-J'ai toujours vu de l'escrime
à la télé,
mais juste de le voir
et de voir ces enfants
se donner à fond comme ça,
c'est quand même
quelque chose.
C'est quelque chose d'incroyable.
Le fait qu'il y ait
zéro récidiviste,
c'est...
-C'est lourd, zéro récidiviste.
-C'est un chiffre incroyable.
-C'est une grande surprise.
-MERCI A DADJU
MERCI A DADJU
MERCI MERCI
-Merci beaucoup
Merci Dadju
Merci à Dadju
...
Merci beaucoup
-MERCI A DADJU
MERCI A DADJU
MERCI MERCI MERCI
-Merci Dadju
Merci à Dadju
...
Merci beaucoup
-Merci, les gars.
-Merci beaucoup.
Musique douce
Merci beaucoup.
...
-Ca a été conçu
pour les mineurs en détention.
Puis, on s'aperçoit
que ça peut s'adresser
à d'autres enfants aussi,
qui ont eu des petits accidents
dans leur vie.
-Voilà, allez !
Prêt !
-Quand on faisait
d'autres sports
avant l'escrime,
ils avaient l'habitude
de se battre
ou bien de montrer
des trucs de force.
Propos en langue étrangère
...
-Je remarque aussi
qu'il y a moins de vols.
Il n'y a plus de vol.
Ils disent qu'il n'y a plus de vol.
Aussi, ils veulent apprendre.
Ces enfants-là veulent apprendre.
-Plus qu'avant ?
-Plus qu'avant.
Propos indistincts
Oui, oui.
Ils veulent apprendre.
C'est comme une compétition.
-Ca a modifié le tempérament,
dans un premier temps,
leur...
leur attention
et aussi la socialisation.
Ils ont plus de responsabilités,
et ils vont apporter
leur touche propre
à la société.
Applaudissements épars
-Cette magnifique méthode prouve
que l'on peut juger un individu,
avoir un avis sur lui,
mais que cet individu peut changer
profondément.
La condamnation
sans retour possible
est clairement dangereuse.
Ces ados ont prouvé
qu'ils pouvaient évoluer
intrinsèquement.
C'est la beauté de l'homme.
Musique douce
...
-Cinq combats, quatre victoires
et une seule défaite.
-Bravo !
...
Qu'est-ce qui vous fait tenir
depuis 30 ans ?
Parce que ça fait 30 ans quand même.
-Ecoutez, je ne sais pas, en fait.
C'est naturel.
Je crois quand même
qu'il y a des moments privilégiés,
des moments de...
Des moments
au coeur de l'homme, vraiment.
Elle hésite.
On est à la rencontre
de ce qui est intrinsèque
chez l'homme,
même si ce sont des jeunes.
Là, on touche du doigt
la réalité humaine
et le bonheur de la rencontre.
Ensuite, bon,
ça peut paraître bateau,
ce que je vais dire, mais...
Je sais pas, quand on sait
d'où viennent ces enfants,
comment ils arrivent
et qu'on les voit redevenir
des enfants
ou redevenir des jeunes,
et puis, pour les plus grands,
devenir des vraies mamans
et des vrais papas,
je pense qu'inconsciemment,
ça doit quand même ressourcer
et régénérer les batteries, oui.
Musique émouvante
...
-Merci !
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
...